pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec françois pour les maths east
journalistes et spécialistes des
institutions européennes monsieur poulet
mathis bienvenus bonsoir
bonjour alors dans deux jours à peu près
les députés européens dont vont ratifié
le proxy que la date de départ du
royaume uni est ce qu'elle peut encore
bouger changer ce qu'on peut s'attendre
à d'autres rebondissements auxquels on a
été habitués pendant plus de trois ans
comme et bien cette fois ci non il est
tout à fait sûr maintenant que les
britanniques le 31 décembre de dire
vendredi soir à minuit
il quitte l'union européenne
effectivement sur le plan politique
c'est extrêmement symbolique s'est
extrêmement fort je comprends que tout
les briques sitter ont envie de fêter
cet événement car effectivement à partir
du 31 janvier
le britannique ne font plus partie de
l'union européenne ces quelques il voit
c'est un petit peu comme une libération
à tel point que certains ont fait des
comparatifs avec la manière dont
finalement les alliés se sont libérés du
nazisme 2 lors de la dernière guerre ce
qui n'était pas forcément d'un très bon
goût comme comparaison et n'empêche que
sur le plan politique c'est important
toutefois sur un plan pratique ça change
pratiquement rien
alors justement à quoi va ressembler
cette europe à 27
pour l'instant c'est à dire le le 1er
février prochain il n'y aura pas de
changement notable puisque toutes les
règles qui fixe les
de droits et obligations du royaume uni
dans l'union européenne sont préservés
sont préservés le temps d'une
négociation qui va durer un an
un an c'est à la fois long mais c'est
aussi très court pour essayer de
renégocier les véritables relations
commerciales entre le royaume-uni et le
reste de l'europe je rappelle que le
royaume uni 60% de ses exportations
c'est vers l'europe
donc il est très important d'avoir de
vrais de vrais accords d'échangés
commerciaux il y aura forcément des
nouveaux accords commerciaux
forcément pas forcément si boris johnson
comme il l'a dit à un moment donné
envisagé de ne pas envisager de
prolongation de cette période de
négociation il faut savoir qu'un accord
commercial en général ces deux à trois
ans de négociations donc jugé que cet
accord sera possible d'être négociées en
annonce est extrêmement téméraire et si
il n'y avait pas d'accord on retomberait
alors dans la configuration d'une
séparation dur avec l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire d'un arbre agility avec
toutes les conséquences que ça peut voir
et qui sera perdant justement de ses
ardeurs excite la grande antenne l'union
européenne les deux alors je dirais
d'abord la grande bretagne de manière
très majoritaires ce hard way site
serait vécue comme une véritable
catastrophe parmi tous les responsables
économiques tous les gens qui suivent un
petit peu la réalité des choses sur
l'avenir possible de la grande bretagne
ce serait une catastrophe pour l'union
européenne ce sera un sérieux coup de
difficile
d'encaisser ça mais c'est surtout pour
la grande bretagne que ça va être
extrêmement difficile parce que la
presse il supposerait que finalement
tout soit à rené par rené vautier
il n'y aurait pu par exemple d'accès des
zones de pêche pour tous les pêcheurs
français
ça serait une véritable catastrophe il y
aurait des départs par centaines
d'emplois notamment dans le centre dans
l'aube le ter qui a voté pour le broc
site sans forcément savoir lorsqu'elle
voter pour le broc site des conséquences
économiques ce que ça dès que ça
risquait d'avoir sur le plan de l'emploi
donc c'est extrêmement important de
trouver pour tous les milieux
économiques de trouver un accord est-ce
que cet accord soit trouvé pour johnson
l'espère l'espère mais il n'a pas les
clés parce que la verrine le véritable
problème est ce qu'on profite de cette
sortie de l'union britannique pour faire
du royaume uni un espèce de singapour ce
que voudrait boris johnson c'est à dire
qu'on baisse les impôts ont fait une
concurrence fiscale effrénée
on essaye et de s'ouvrir au niveau de la
réglementation pour abandonner toutes
les réglementations tatillonnes
européenne en faisant cela ils se
mettraient en concombre en concurrence
directe extrêmement dur avec l'union
européenne raison pour laquelle pour les
négociateurs européens il n'est pas
question que le royaume uni pendant les
négociations joue cette carte est
injustement gala merkel l'a dit hier ce
sont ses mots le royaume uni sera
dorénavant un concurrent un autre porte
c'est possible avant tout à fait si
effectivement johnson décide avec une
majorité qu'il a actuellement deux sites
par exemple de faire une baisse
drastique des impôts c'est à dire de
rentrer dans une période de concurrence
fiscale effrénée
s'il dessine par exemple de changer
toute la réglementation européenne au
profit d'une réglementation beaucoup
plus souple accepte n'importe quel
produit par exemple des poulet aux
hormones des états unis et c'est à ce
moment là on est en concurrence directe
mais la conséquence c'est que si
prenez ce risque de faire une véritable
concurrence fiscale réglementaires etc
il se mettrait en situation de se voir
refuser l'accès au marché unique
or les anglais pour essayer de tirer un
profit d'un bric sites centraux d'accous
l'important c'est pour eux de pouvoir
conserver l'accès au marché unique donc
le marché est qu'il ait aucun intérêt à
avoir un art da brick site
personne n'a intérêt à voir arbres
excite mais on fait un petit peu
miroiter dans l'idée aux gens que les
anglais vous récupérer toutes leurs
libertés
et ben non c'est faux cils welmant ils
veulent profiter des avantages
eh bien s'ils veulent continuer à
profiter des avantages d'une union
européenne il faudrait qu'il continue à
accepter les règles
françois poulet mathis merci d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes